the David Pakman show, sub reddit@davidpakman.com
slash Reddit has surpassed 15,000 viewers
and listeners.
Some interesting posts I spotted on the subreddit
this morning.
David Pacman is bad for the left movement
in general, says user RMX two 45.
David does have some good points every now
and then, but he really comes off as MSNBC
light.
He tried to make it seem like Bernie and Warren
had no difference.
Only someone who is trying to Gaslight people
in general would make this claim.
Um, I hate to tell you, but I have multiple
segments about how Bernie and Warren are not
the same.
And in fact, I almost have been to a fault
going out of my way to issue disclaimers every
time this comes up.
So that a, I am not misunderstood as suggesting
that Warren and Bernie are the same and the
last two weeks I've been going doubly out
of my way to explain that.
So this is either someone who is misinformed
or someone making a bad faith argument, but
because they are making it, I guess in a respectful
way, it is fine for others to respond to them
on the subreddit.
That's the type of engagement that you can
participate in at David pakman.com/reddit
uh, another, uh, quite a few posts actually
noting that the Twitch stream of the debates
with my commentary on Tuesday evening went
down and a lot of confusion as to what happened.
And indeed Twitch took down my live stream
of the debate and commentary.
They took down Sam seeders as well, which
was on Twitch.
I heard that Sam switched over to Vimeo.
We do it on YouTube and get shut down.
So he switched to Twitch.
That got shut down and Sam then going to Vimeo,
I guess, which is like kind of tier three
option.
I didn't do that.
I just ended up going to bed.
But, um, we are, uh, thinking about what to
do for subsequent debates.
It seems mostly it's CNN that aggressively
enforces copyright in this way.
At least for now.
We've not had the problems with the other
networks, but you know who, who knows what
will happen at the November debate.
But I will keep you apprised as to if and
where I will be streaming commentary.
Lastly, producer Pat Ford is going to be taking
over as host of not of the David Pakman show.
Just have the Friday bonus show.
Okay.
Pat did such a great job when I was out for
my emergency appendectomy that um, people
wrote in saying, you know, you should just
let Pat host the bonus show every once in
awhile and we're going to do that on Fridays.
But Pat wants to hear from you, what do you
want him doing on the bonus show?
What do you want him talking about on the
bonus show?
Do you have questions for Pat that you want
him to answer on the bonus show?
So if you go to our subreddit right now, uh,
David pakman.com/reddit you will see up stickied
at the top, a post called I'm producer.
Pat asked me anything.
You can post your questions or topic ideas
for Pat.
Uh, on the Friday bonus show in that thread,
subscribe to the subreddit.
Takes a second.
It's a great place for political discussion,
David pakman.com/reddit